hi in this module i'm going to talk
about beam search a really simple
algorithm for finding approximate
maximum weight assignments efficiently
when you're in a hurry and don't want to
incur the full cost of backtracking
search
so just as to review
remember constraint satisfaction or csp
is defined by a factor graph which
consists of a set of variables x1
through xn where each xi can be
at some element of a domain i
and a set of factors f1 through fm where
each factor function fj
is a function that takes
assignment and returns a non-negative
number and usually the factor function
depends only on a subset of the
variables
so each assignment little x to all the
variables
has a weight and that weight is given by
simply the product of all the factors
applied to the assignment
and the objective is to find the maximum
weight assignment
so let us revisit the object object
tracking example so in this example
we're trying to track an object over
time
and at each time step we record a noisy
sensor reading of its position so at
time step one we see zero times f2 we
see two times f3 c2
and we can the question is
what was the trajectory that object took
is this one or this one or something
else
we modeled this
problem as a csp
with
x1 x2 and x3
we defined factors that captured our
intuitions about the problem
o1 captures the fact that the actual
position should be close to the sensor
reading
so
2
is the weight assigned to 0. so 0 x1
equals 0 is favored and x1 equals 2 is
disallowed
similarly
o2
favors x2 equals 2
o3 favors x3 equals 2
and finally the transition factors
t1 and t2
favor
adjacent xi's which are close so a
distance of zero will get
to a weight of two whereas a distance of
one will get
one and so on
okay and you can click on this demo
to actually play with um
this
uh csp
we'll come back to this in a bit
okay so this is the object tracking um
example so now
so far we've seen backtracking search as
a way to compute
maximal white uh assignments
and backtracking search essentially does
uh exhaustive depth first search of the
entire tree in the worst case which can
take a very very long time
so how can we avoid this well we have to
give up on something and what we're
going to give up on
is correctness
so what we're going to do is simply not
backtrack
so let's start with something called the
greedy search algorithm
so again we start with the empty
assignment
we consider
possible settings of let's say x1
so let's say there's two possible
settings
and we're just going to choose one of
them whichever ones has the
highest
weight
and the weight of remember of a partial
assignment is the product of all the
factors that you can evaluate so far
so let's pick with this one
again let's set x2
there's two possible ways to set it
let's pick the better one and keep on
going until we reach a complete
assignment and then we just return that
so
formally
what greedy search is doing is starting
with a partial assignment which is empty
and then it's going through each of the
variables x1 through xn
i'm going to try to extend the partial
assignment to set
x i so
for each possible value
that i can assign x i i'm going to form
a
potential candidate partial assignment
and call it xp
and then i'm going to compute the weight
of each of these xv's and then choose
the one with the highest weight
so important caveat is this is
definitely not guaranteed to find the
maximum weight assignment even local
even though locally it appears to be
optimizing and finding the value with
the best
weight
so let's look at this um
demo to see how it works on object
tracking okay so
here we have the csp that's defined
and i'm going to step through this
algorithm so
initially
i extend the empty assignment to
assignments that
only
fill in x1 so x1 could be 0 1 or 2 and
these are the weights of these partial
three partial assignments
remember the sensor reading was zero
so therefore x one equals zero has a
larger one
so next step i prune i keep only the
best candidate which in this case is x
one equals zero
so then i go to um i equals two and i
extend
that assignment to
uh three possible settings of x2 compute
their weights
and then i keep the best one which in
case this case is uh another one
and now i extend again to x3
three possible values to set x3 compute
the weights of these um
well now
complete assignments
and then i choose uh the best one
so in this case 3d search ends up with
the assignment 0 1 1
with a weight of 4. and if you remember
this
this example the best
weight assignment have weight 8. so four
is definitely not the right answer but
it's not zero either it found something
okay so what's the problem with 3d
search is that it's too myopic it only
keeps the best canada single best
candidate
so beam search is just the natural
generalization
of greedy where i'm keeping at most k
candidates at each level
so let's say k equals four
so i'm going to start with empty
assignment i'm going to x uh extend
and then i don't need to prune because
there's only two
um possible partial assignments here
and i have a capacity of four
i'm going to extend again
again i don't need to prune
but then next i'm going to extend each
of
the elements on my beam the partial
assignments
extend each of these
and now i have eight and i now i need to
reduce the eight partial assignments to
four
and to do this i'm going to simply
compute the weight of each of these
eight partial assignments and then take
the four which have the highest weight
and now let's suppose those are these
four
and then i'll continue only expanding
the ones i've kept
and then
keeping the ones the again the top four
and then keep on going
so notice that
visually
i'm exploring only a very very small
fraction
of the tree but i'm doing this kind of
holistically looking down uh the tree i
kind of multiple uh diff
i could be exploring
different parts of the tree um at the
same time
so formally
beam search uh keeps at most k
candidates
of partial assignments
i'm gonna initialize the candidate set
to be
just the single partial assignment which
is empty
now again like greedy search i'm going
to go through the variables one at a
time i'm going to extend
in this case i'm going to consider each
partial assignment in c
and each possible value
that i can assign x i
and i'm gonna do perform the extend
uh the assignment
and i'm just gonna keep track a c prime
is going to be the new set of candidates
and then now i'm going to prune that set
by computing the weight for each
element of c prime
and just keeping the top k elements
so this is not guaranteed to find the
maximum weight assignment
either
but sometimes it works better so let's
look at this example
object tracking
and
i stay extend from the empty assignment
to get three partial assignments to x1
um
i prune to the top three so nothing gets
removed and then extend
so each of these three
partial assignments gets extended into
three additional ones now i have nine
and now i'm going to prune down from
nine to three so that will keep
all the
assignments here with a positive void
and now i extend again
to
find settings of x3
compute each of these weights and then
i'm going to take the top
assignments
okay so now
notice that
the top assignment that i have right now
is
one two two with a weight of eight
in this case i got lucky and i found
actual max weight assignment but in
general you won't be guaranteed
okay so what is the time complexity of
beam search because one of the
advantages is that's supposed to be fast
so let's do a simple calculation here so
suppose we have n variables which is the
depth of this tree
and suppose that each of the variables
has
v elements which is going to be the
branching factor here
and then the beam size is k
okay so what is the time
that it takes to run beam search
it's going to be for each of
the variables
each level of this tree
we're going to have a set of candidates
which is of size k
and
the extension
is is going to take each of these k
and extend it into b candidates so then
i'm going to end up with kb
extended candidates total
and then i'm going to take have to take
the top k
so the time it takes to take a list of
kb elements and select the top k
elements is kb log k by building a heap
so the total time is n kb log k
and importantly
this is linear in the number of
variables whereas backtracking search
would be exponential and the number of
variables
okay so let us summarize now
so beam search is a fairly simple
heuristic to
approximate uh maximum weight
assignments and it's really done if
you're really in a hurry and you don't
really care about getting maximum weight
assignment because you probably won't
so um the nice thing about beam search
is it has this parameter k which allows
you to control the trade-off between
efficiency and accuracy
so if you're really in a hurry you set k
equals one you just get greedy search
which sometimes actually gets you pretty
good answers
but and if as you increase k more and
more
um if you can increase k to infinity
then you'll definitely
search the entire search tree and you
will get the optimal answer but this is
basically exponential time
one thing to know about uh beam search
with kuan's infinity it's it is
performing a breadth first search of the
tree because at each it performs level
by level and explores all the nodes in a
tree
systematically
so using this analogy i want to
end with a final
note here which is that that tracking
search
is really like doing a debt first search
on the search tree it dives deeply into
one
harsh complete assignment
and then backtracks and then finds
another complete assignment and
backtracks looking kind of one
assignment at a time
whereas beam search
is more akin to breadth first search
where we're proceeding level by level
but the main difference with breadth
research is that we're doing this
heuristic pruning at each level to make
sure that we don't have too many
candidates
and the way it's using using that um
doing that pruning is based on the
factors
that it can evaluate so far so for beam
search to work
you really need it to be the case that
the factors are local and they can be
evaluated as much as possible along the
way and not all at the very end
all right so that's the end of this
module